what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things youtube channel
today i have a special guest on the
channel who came on my show this week
eddie come on you know where it is i've
been here a few times so you know you
should be used to my face by now before
i start guys do not forget to subscribe
to the channel and bring that
notification bell the way you're going
to be notified of my daily videos you
already know if you have watched two or
more of my videos and you do not
subscribe we have beef okay
beef all right so
to start tell the people where they can
find you
uh so you can find me on my personal um
who's underscore eddie underscore um or
you can find me on the domino effect
podcast um on the other half of the
podcast over there so give me a shout
okay so the reason i invited you here
was because you said you're on the verge
of becoming a conservative after
after our show
you know what
you helped me to identify a truth that
uh i've been battling with
and
i think i'm ready to identify as a black
conservative and listen it's gonna cause
an uproar because i was banging for the
liberals but
the games changed i realized my true
self your true self okay
um i wasn't expecting you to be this
enthusiastic yet but okay i'm still
learning i i thought i thought this
video was gonna be the okay well i'm
still learning this is gonna help okay
okay so
thomas sowell
is an economist okay
and this man just spits facts okay and
he's very smart
and i want to interview him but
he has denied me every single time
positive affirmations it will come
but um this is he's being interviewed
about one of his books and i love thomas
soul because he's one of the people that
made me a conservative okay interesting
so you was a liberal before too no i was
more like
undecided okay so
i want to see if he presses my liberal
values or whether he's going to sway me
to solidify my conservatives okay i'm
glad we're on the fence okay
it happens to me all the time and it
happened just this week a young person
i'd never met introduced himself to me
and said that when he saw our guest
today
on an earlier episode of this program he
felt he was seeing a man who knew how to
think
dr thomas sowell on uncommon knowledge
now
i'm getting excited yeah
[Music]
welcome to uncommon you got it you got
to switch up what you listen to if you
become a conservative is looking like
yeah this is all we listen to just
letting you know i'm still sticking to
my rap i can't change that okay well
we'll work on that knowledge i'm peter
robinson
thomas soule has studied and taught
economics intellectual history and
social policy at institutions that
include cornell brandeis ucla and
amherst now a senior fellow at the
hoover institution dr sowell has
published more than a dozen books
including the classic a conflict of
visions
coming soon a revised edition of his
most recent volume discrimination and
disparities
tom soul welcome thank you
you grew up in harlem dropped out of
high school to join the marine corps
during the korean war
received an undergraduate degree from
harvard
a masters from columbia
and your doctorate from the university
of chicago
all of which pales by comparison with
the fact that you once tried out for the
brooklyn dodgers
but
during this period from harlem
to the university of chicago
throughout your 20s you've said you
spent most of the decade of your 20s as
a marxist yes
why what was it what
what was the attraction
well i guess at first
was uh
very puzzled see
there's one little correction i would
make
at age 16 i was a dropout
high school dropout
uh and i went to work full time
as a western union messenger
and uh delivering telegrams did
lorraine's halloween we better say that
because there will be a generation that
won't know what western union was
because yeah that's true too right uh
and so i i work i worked in the
area of manhattan called the chelsea
district which is around 23rd street
9th avenue
and at the end of the day i had several
ways of getting back home the easiest
and fastest way was a subway which was a
nickel in those days
when i was feeling flush i might go for
a bus
for a dime
and then when i was really getting
reckless i would take the fifth avenue
bus which was the elite of the buses
was 15 cents so i would walk over to
fifth avenue take that bus
and it would take me up uh through all
the
glamorous parts of fifth avenue past the
empire state building uh past the great
stores and things of that so what
uh and then on 57th street it would turn
and and
this is just the elite part of town sure
right right right there where the park
starts yes and then and you
know this park starts at 59th oh sorry
50s 57th i would turn over again the
same kind of scene past carnegie hall
right a columbus circle there was no
trump tower at that time and uh on up to
about 72nd street and go out to fifth
ave out to the riverside drive which is
another elite area so for miles after
that you'd have all these wonderful
luxury apartment buildings and so on
and finally around
129th or 30th street
it would go on a long viaduct
and then he would do a right turn back
into the
occupied area and there you'd see the
tenements
and i would wonder why is this
i mean why why this huge disparity
and there was nobody else there was no
other other explanation around
there there was nothing there was
nothing there other than marxism uh i
know i stumbled across i had not read
marx but i
as i bought a second hand pair a set of
encyclopedias
small set
for some ridiculously low price
and uh there they i looked up karl marx
i heard the name and the stuff that he
said
seemed to make sense
and then later on i would get more and
more into it
uh and uh
the
argument was that the the rich had
gotten rich by taking from the poor
right
and well that was that was one
explanation but what was interesting
there was no other explanation out there
really and that's true
okay have you heard that had that
argument how
they always talk about the one percent
what do you think of it
in what sense though
like
they always act like like they always
say the rich are getting richer and the
poor are getting poorer yes which is
true but we have some of the best
standard of living
ever in human history yes that's true
also so why do people hate the one
percent
um for the most part people hate the one
percent because
there's a disparity in terms of the
distribution of wealth so the one
percent
are i think it's something like there's
a small fraction of people that own the
majority of the wealth in the world
so if there was a redistribution of
wealth then there'd be an even higher
standard of living because whilst you
have a higher standard of living
mental health and stuff of that nature
has also decreased as a consequence of
people's living standards right but why
are why is everyone else entitled to
their wealth i mean what would we do
without amazon
um so i don't believe that the wealth
should be taken from them they're
entitled to that welfare they worked
hard to get that
um and again that's probably part of the
problem with liberals yeah is the fact
that they feel entitled before stuff
they didn't have to work for
the only part that i disagree with is
for those who
who are more slant underhanded
about it um but people like jeff bezos
um elon musk they work hard to make
their money so by all means keep your
money the same thing with footballers
footballers get paid a wage for the work
that they do so listen live your life
okay
too largely in our
colleges universities today but so so by
the time you went to harvard undergrad
well so
you drop out at the age of 16
and you start reading marks in your late
teens i know i start reading walks
yes 1949
at age 19. age 19. and then you're in
the marine corps for
a couple of years what what was it two
three years oh two years it was actually
one
one year 11 months and five days but
who's counting
all right so by the time you went to
harvard
you had already become intellectually
engaged with marxism yes and remained
and harvard didn't talk you out of it
and colla the study of economics at
harvard didn't talk you out of it nor
did getting a masters at columbia nor
did getting a doctorate
at chicago
dissuade you from marxism is that and
you studied with milton friedman of all
people how could you have sat in milton
friedman's classroom and remained a
marxist some people are just stubborn
but
what really changed me
was not the university of chicago
it was
my first job working in a professional
capacity of the government i was a
summer intern this is after chicago or
no no while i was still a graduate
student got it uh
and so during the summer of vacation i
worked in the u.s department of labor
and i began to realize from a number of
things
that
the government is not simply the
personification of the general will like
rousseau or others
the government is an institute the
government institutions have their own
institutional
interests
one involved in minimum wage law i was a
big supporter of that
but i also knew that there was an
argument that minimum wage law is simply
price low wage workers out of a job
and uh my my first assignment was was
dealt with minimum wages in puerto rico
and as i looked at the numbers i would
see as they would jack up the minimum
wage this is a number
number of jobs would go down and so
forth but there were two explanations
one was that of the economist that you
priced the people out of out of a job
and the other was that there are there
were
hurricanes in the country puerto rico
you see
during the
sugar harvesting and therefore i was
studying the sugar industry and
therefore it destroyed a lot of the crop
therefore you wouldn't hire as many
workers now in chicago had been taught
that if there are two different theories
there should be somewhat some empirical
evidence in principle that could
distinguish what would happen under one
theory from what would happen under the
other right and so i wrestled with that
for the most of the summer and one
morning i came in and i said i got it
what we need are data on the amount of
sugar clean standing in the fields
before the hurricane struck
and as i waited for the congratulations
i could see stricken looks around me in
the room like this guy has stumbled on
something they will ruin us all
you know
and they say well we don't have those
data i said oh i'll bet the department
of agriculture has it he said well but
that doesn't mean we haven't
you'd have to have a request go up the
chain of command to the secretary of
labor he would then confer with the
secretary of agriculture it would come
down the chain of command and
the department of agriculture to whoever
has those numbers and so on i said good
well they say a journey of a thousand
miles begins with a single step so i
will now submit my request to the
secretary of labor which i did and i am
still patiently awaiting this reply
and the institutional fear of the number
was what that it oh the us department of
labor administers the minimum wage law
and i and the uh money and the careers
of perhaps a third or some other
significant percentage of the member of
the labor department's resources come
from administering the minimum wage law
one of the real farces of all this is
that the law itself section 4-d i still
remember requires the labor department
to study the employment effects of
minimum wages
and those studies are absolutely a farce
in fact some years after i left i did an
article saying why those those
studies were a farce and when i came
back later on to the labor department to
do some research one of the older
librarians who remembered me turned to
the younger librarian and she said this
is the man who wrote that article that
has everybody up in arms
so you became you began to be dissuaded
about of marxism and of government of
government in general because the the
the government uh is not out there at
the personification of the national
interest
so did you ever have a moment like that
where you started to quote because you
said
before the show obviously you you were
more liberal or like democrat so when
did you start to question
the government
i've always christian government oh okay
i've never trusted a government
so you've always been a conservative
kind of i've always had i've always had
conservative principles but i can maybe
a labor heart okay so like again my
parents came from nigeria
what supported them in their quest to
the uk was the labour government yeah so
naturally i have to be grateful but at
the same time they don't represent me
and my values anymore
um but yeah i've never ever ever ever
trusted government i've always been a
massive conspiracy theorist obviously
the rabbit hole it was bad when i was
younger but no i've always thought that
the government had their own interests
and yeah you know um
do you know who is affected the most by
minimum wage laws
tell me teenagers
they're the ones who are priced out of
the job
interested because a lot of times when
they think the people that are making
minimum wage they kind of
make it seem like it's like older people
but it's it's not it's the people on the
bottom of the totem pole true why do you
why do you need a living wage when
you're a teenager you're living off your
parents
you have no
skills right rightly so and it results
in unpaid internships
so then what's the alternative
letting people accept the wage that they
want
okay like you you don't accept a job
that you're not worth
like if i said okay i'm worth a hundred
thousand dollars but nobody's gonna pay
me that can you price yourself out the
market yeah and that's what that does is
they're saying okay the lowest skilled
job is worth twelve dollars an hour or
whatever it is
and
then they're like okay let me buy a
machine to flip the burgers instead of
hiring someone so what would you say
you're like a neo-liberal then so you
just believe in complete market freedom
and there's no governance whatsoever
um
not no government um but when i don't
believe in minimum wage laws because i
think as as i have the right to accept
whatever wage i want to accept and when
you insert a minimum wage laws they're
saying i don't have a right as the
worker to accept any wage i want to
accept like what if someone their dream
was to work at a youtube channel yeah
and they're a teenager they wanted to
take it for five bucks an hour true they
should have the yeah they should have
the right to do that but then if i can't
pay them the 12 or whatever it is the
other option is zero they did nothing
no opportunity right so why can't they
accept that job and i as a business
owner should be able to offer someone
whatever i want
the people i've hired like it's not like
i pay them nothing
but or
the other option is i could hire someone
here right or i could go overseas and
hire someone in india true but it isn't
part of the reason is like slave labor
almost because obviously if given the
opportunity
as capitalist if i can pay you as
minimal as i can then i probably will
yeah that's that's the point because you
want to increase your profits yeah but
if you if you're a skilled worker you do
that for six months and you try to get a
new job true true true if you work hard
and build skills
then they can't replace you but arguably
wouldn't that make the notion of this
one percent potentially worse obviously
we don't know the consequences of it or
the results of it as we haven't
experienced the world
that was governed that way but
inarguably if you gave more power to the
capitalists wouldn't the read the
distribution of wealth be far worse than
what it is now
what what what's wrong with it being
with them getting richer if everybody's
getting richer
the question is does everybody get rich
at all because i think
people well hundred years ago people are
people aren't intelligent enough to be
opportunistic in these situations you're
gonna get really smart people who are
really opportunistic and they're gonna
utilize their
mental capacity to
subdue these people so that it's really
again the intelligent people that will
prosper and the ones who are more
malleable will suffer okay do you think
you have to be that smart to be a
garbage man of course
garbage men of course i understand that
one not not i don't remember jordan
peterson breaks down the
what iq you should be to work in every
job it's funny because my iq they
it was a guy who used to work in sales
that's what he said i should have worked
yeah yeah yeah it was he didn't have
youtuber on there oddly
i went to the soul's teaching yeah but
um i remember that plumber was like
lower and like trades because it's all
about repetition
yeah yeah that's easier to master yeah
but you can make six figures easy as a
contractor yeah yeah but then you also
have to be savvy to how you get those
contracts
what do you mean so you have to get so
like at the bottom level of being a
plumber on a very basic level being told
what to do it'll be easy to be sent out
to jobs but then to have that to take
that next step you need to become
business savvy you need to learn and
iterate but again questionably
do people have the capacity to do so
especially in the market like that
i don't know i i think so yeah yeah
because
i know some pretty like at least book
smart they were not that intelligent in
high school but they're the ones
laughing now true true because they have
in the us anyway but they have no
college debt
and they're they're making like 70 80k a
here because in the us they have no
trades people i worked at a plumbing
tech company for a couple years after
college and they like are begging people
to work for them oh really yeah because
no one wants to do it it's a thing here
as well the p there's there's no trace
people that's why
um that's why i guess the whole brexit
situation happened like you've all taken
our jobs but most british people don't
want to work those jobs because they
don't believe it's high
status enough but these are really well
paying jobs yeah it's i mean it's supply
and demand do you believe in a universal
basic income
no no why are you entitled to an income
and why do i have to pay for it because
i was reading the book utopia for
realists of course it's a very very
liberal book by the title yeah um but
there were studies that showed that um
the benefits of the universal basic
income in terms of alleviating the
stresses of having to think about the
day-to-day meal so if you alleviate the
stress of thinking about the typical um
necessities of life um you have more
time to think and be more creative so
for example you wanted to start youtube
if you had a universal basic income but
have what came from a low-income family
if they alleviate all the kind of
average costs that you need to survive
then you can concentrate on your
creativity and your craft
yeah i mean that's that sounds nice but
what's the evidence that that would work
so in the book they do reference a few
trial tests in the us and in ireland i
believe in those two places and it was
said to have worked some people did
abuse it but far more people used it
correctly um as opposed to abusing and
america was worth what government but
although close to actually they kind of
did that during the freaking look down
i know so many people that just weren't
working yeah yeah because they got free
government [ __ ] see but i think it's
also what's required is a process of
re-education and how to
use that because obviously if you just
give people money without any question
and then and then the question is what's
the what's the universal what what
number and politicians are gonna keep
fighting to make that number bigger and
bigger and bigger to win votes true true
so why and why do they get to decide
what number is a universal basic income
and why do i have to pay for it i need
to always come in
like why
yeah because okay i take my dad right my
dad made every he came from nothing
right
he made every good decision that he he
possibly could have made right he's the
top half a percent of earners in the us
so
he he came from nothing he was one of 13
kids they lived in the south side of
chicago and rural wisconsin they like
kind of went back and forth and
and he doesn't drink he doesn't party he
doesn't smoke he made every good
decision you possibly could have made
and he he left money like we're all
gonna get money right so some people
would look at me and say that's not fair
right but it's not fair to my dad that
you got like that random people get to
have his income when he left it for his
career and this is where my liberal
values yeah
go off the cliff because
i used to be i i would happily say that
i used to be of this victim mentality
especially as a black male yeah that you
know i'm entitled to certain things you
know because you know i've had to suffer
unjustly but then i realized that you
know like
things aren't handed to you in this
world and if you make something of
yourself then then you can create a
legacy for your family as well and it's
not like 100 years ago where
there were things in place to stop
people from becoming successful now you
can genuinely become successful if you
work hard enough and now that i work the
mad hours that i work
i want to keep the money that i'm making
well that's that's the thing people
don't understand it comes at a cost my
dad works 80 hours a week for 40 years
yes i don't know many people that want
to do that listen i i hadn't had a day
off since the last week of april my
first day off from work was
um last weekend when i went to a
festival so to think that i work that
hard
just to give money away to stuff that i
don't want to spend money on and
shouldn't you most rich people i know
are really generous i mean my parents
adopted three kids that aren't theirs
but they should have the right to pick
and choose who they are generous to yeah
and i completely agree though you just
want a ubi no to everybody and the thing
is is now that i've become a
hard-working individual i've always been
hard-working but i've always had this
why do i have to work so hard like why
am i killing myself this isn't going to
make me happy etc but then
as a person who's discovered the mission
you put all that aside and said you know
what i'm going to make it for myself and
build and add to my legacy because
that's important to me now that i've
discovered my mission that's where i
think these liberal values are starting
to change and then even coming on your
platform and seeing how you're doing
things i'm like yo see homegirl over
there
she's doing bits yeah i'm just like yeah
i want to slash that
[Laughter]
all right let's let's keep going let's
go
they have their own interest and the
labor department was clearly an interest
in
keeping the minimum wage because that's
that's their jobs and careers all right
and power in your which brings us if i
may to one of my favorite books your
2000 book this is a beat up old copy
this book conflict of vision yes which
you published in 2007 and you lay out
i'm sorry 1987. i beg your pardon
in 2007.
well beat up as this book is it turns
out this is the reprint sorry 1987
and you lay out two
competing ways of looking at economics
and policy really two competing ways of
looking at life that go back at least
200 years
the constrained vision
and the unconstrained vision
the constrained vision i'm quoting from
a conflict of visions sees the evils of
the world as deriving from the limited
and unhappy choices available given the
inherent moral and intellectual
limitations
of human beings close quote
so the constrained vision under itself
understands itself as constrained
by the limitations of reality itself yes
is that yeah that's correct yes okay
in other words they cannot proceed as so
many do that good things happen
automatically but bad things are
somebody's fault
got it got it and then to continue here
the constrained vision
again
quoting from a conflict of visions
for the amelioration
improvement of the human condition the
constrained vision relies on
certain social processes such as moral
traditions the marketplace or families
not government
so explain that
why why do we rely why do we rely on
so on processes
rather than the will of the people
instituting changes to improve our
condition
well
it doesn't ignore government
even for the market to work you have to
have a government as
europe discovered when the roman empire
collapsed and the economy has collapsed
also
but i guess
one of the reasons would be that with
the government you have surrogate
decision makers and they cannot possibly
know as much as the individuals whose
personal decisions have been preempted
i see i see all right which brings us to
the unconstrained vision
when again i'm quoting you when rousseau
said that man is born free but
everywhere in chains
he expressed the essence of the
unconstrained vision which the in which
the fundamental problem is not nature or
man but institutions yes would you
explain that one well he has the notion
that again that that good things happen
naturally
uh if there are bad things it's because
uh institutions including civilization
itself have have made these bad things
happen and of course uh and i think that
that's really the the implicit
assumption behind a lot of things that
are said on the left today
uh and
why in my most recent book i go to a lot
of trouble to show that uh in nature
there's nothing resembling equal
opportunity that wherever you look
around the country around around the
world
you find people who live up in the
mountains poor and backwards even in the
richest countries
uh
including the united states
i believe the the poorest country in the
united states the county rather
uh was in a mountain community
uh which was almost 100 white
somewhere in appalachia west virginia
yeah southern ohio right yes
uh
and that men in that in that county
had a life expectancy 10 years less
than men
in a county in in virginia
and the constrained the unconstrained
vision says let's fix that we surely we
can pass a law that would improve that
and the constrained vision says well now
wait a moment
if people who live in isolated pockets
and mountains are poor and backwards all
around the world and we see this pattern
over and over and over again
maybe there's something very deeply
rooted in reality about that
that's hard for us to get at correct yes
all right
so in the book a conflict of visions
you're very dispassionate and very
analytical
and you lay out the unconstrained vision
and you lay out the constrained vision
and you don't really come out blazing
in favor of one or the other no
you know that is not a book meant to
commit to uh
show one vision is better than the other
it's there to show you what what they
are and what you're assuming if you if
you go one direction or another okay and
it's to encourage people to understand
the implicit assumptions behind all this
without which you you're just a
lot at loose ends all right so
pondering all this i i
noticed something a
column that you wrote this is a couple
years ago
in which you rebutted nicholas kristoff
of the new york times and kristoff
had ascribed the gaps between african
americans and whites in america gaps in
wealth gaps in educational achieve the
usual gaps
to and this is a quotation from kristoff
to the lingering effects of slavery
close quote oh yeah and here's tom soul
quote
if we wanted to be serious
about evidence
we might compare where black stood 100
years after the end of slavery with
where they stood after 30 years of the
liberal welfare state in other words we
could compare hard evidence on the
legacy of slavery with hard evidence
on the legacy of liberals close quote
and so there it is life is hard you use
the word hard
you use the word serious you use
evidence
tom soul
is a man of the constrained vision
through and through and through correct
yes
no no
yes you know
part of a vanishing breed i might right
so
when so when you were a marxist
the notion explain that because the mark
marxism
well but no no yeah so that's when i was
a marxist i had the same intellectual
standards right and that that's what
eventually led me away from it
oh i see in other words i did i hadn't
done all the research i hadn't gone
around the world
looking for evidence yes yes okay
so so a big thing for me when i was
became more sure that i was conservative
right
is when i found out that
disparity does not equal discrimination
and you know how we talked about the
wage gap yes and like when you find out
the reasons behind the wage gap yes
it's the same thing in the u.s when they
talk about the gap between black and
white wealth okay because so if they
were going to measure
what causes a gap in between
two groups of people right
they would and in that case they're
gonna test like is it racism right
they would take another group of people
that also had dark skin to see
how did they perform in the same
environment like in the us right and
they did that with indians like people
from india
and they have a higher
they make more money like they have
higher wealth than white people
and so that indicates they have higher
wealth than white people in the us yeah
interesting yeah and same with nigerian
americans i knew about that one yeah
yeah so
it's
interesting because
i always just figured like it was
because of racism
but like the more he brings out
different evidence it made me think
maybe there's other factors
i've always believed that there were
other factors um racism being one of the
more dominant reasons for it but then
there's also
other coinciding factors
um
for example
if you go back long enough when they
were like
black enterprise and black banks and
black business etc
when that was all taken away from black
people and and obviously for them at the
time in the us
probably more specific to the earth in
the uk okay when you remove a culture
you remove the basic foundations of when
was it taken away i couldn't tell you
exactly when but like for what oh
after slavery
so after slavery when it was abolished
obviously black people built up their
own businesses and for a time they were
quite successful
um and then i remember exactly what
happened but things changed a lot of the
black businesses died out for whatever
reason the bank stopped giving loans to
black people which didn't allow them to
to gather the capital to invest and
invest in a community and it's often
said that in order for any community to
be successful and your race to be
successful money needs to bounce within
that community i think it's 12 times
um with jewish people it was something
like 14 indians it was quite high as
well white people's around it was i
think it was the the average and with
black people it was like six hours
so we don't spend money within our
community which is also part of the
problem okay so he's gonna talk about i
hope i hope this is the correct clip i'm
thinking of but he's gonna talk about
some of the reasons okay that you might
not know about okay okay so socialism is
a great idea
that does not mean it's a great reality
one of the things that disturbs me
tremendously is about this enthusiasm
for bernie sanders and socialism at a
time when people are literally starving
in venezuela and oil-rich country
you know
and they you know they're breaking into
in the grocery stores to try to get food
and they're fleeing to neighboring
countries most of which are not all that
prosperous themselves but that but at
least you don't starve to death in them
uh and none of that makes a bit a bit of
difference
i don't think most of these people who
are out there cheering for bernie
sanders have given a thought to
venezuela
to the evidence that's right to the
evidence yeah all right
which brings us to
something that you refer to in a number
of columns you as the retrogression the
experience of african americans in this
country
economic progress i'm quoting you
despite the grand myth that black
economic progress began or celebrated
with the passage of the civil rights
laws and the war on poverty programs of
the 1960s the fact is that the poverty
rate among blacks
fell from 87 in 1940 to 47 in 1960
but over the next 20 years the poverty
rate among blacks fell another 18
percentage points this was just the
continuation of
a previous economic trend
but at a slower rate of progress it was
not
some grand deliverance close quote
that is so counter
to what we are taught in school what
appears on the editorial pages of
newspapers
that i have i feel as though i want to
ask you you really want to stick with
that
that assortment i i i have more evidence
in my most most recent book that
discrimination and disparities
i point out that this really is a
pattern not peculiar to blacks or even
to the united states that you can see
the same thing in england you can see it
in any number of other countries that
the poor were or were much worse off
economically let's say in the first half
of the 20th century
and yet they in terms of their own
behavior
they were they were they had they were
far more decent
societies
and afterwards after after this welfare
state that's supposed to make them
better off and and better human beings
that's when the crime rate skyrocketed
on both sides of the atlantic
uh the british were not famous for being
perhaps the most polite
considerate society in the world
prior to that
after that you get things like the 2011
riots over there between london
manchester where they're going through
this they they they
anticipated ferguson uh and uh and uh
baltimore
by a few years
and the same thing is the the burning
down of buildings the throwing of
gasoline bombs that pull the whole
schmear
uh and none of those people were
descendants of slaves
so so that
poor people were doing if the the lesson
of the 20th century is something like
poor people including in this country
african americans
were improving their lot and leading
fundamentally decent lives until the
government decided to help them yeah yes
that's a that's a fair statement
they're better off
economically because of what's been
given right but of course when you when
you have the crime rate
i mean i i got i got the first inkling
of this some years back when i was uh
at some school in harlem doing some
research
and i looked out the window and i
mentioned in passing that when i was a
little kid i used to walk my dog in that
park
and looks of horror came over the
students faces
nobody in his right mind would have a
child going to that park
walking a dog or not
the principal was warning these students
not to cross this park which is about a
block a half wide
even in groups of six
uh when i and when i tell them about how
in this hot summer nights i would sleep
out on the fire escapes in harlem
they looked at me like i was a man from
mars people were doing that all over new
york they were doing it in philadelphia
washington wherever i've known people
that was a common thing for portland we
didn't have the money for air
conditioning right you slept out on on
the fire escape or in the parks
where walton grew up in a walter
williams walter williams grew up in a uh
a housing project in philadelphia he was
saying on the hot summer nights the
people would be in this project have
little balconies they'd sleep out on the
balconies and the ones on the first
floor who didn't have balconies would
sleep out in the yard
and that there were old men who would
you could see sit on a hot summer night
sitting outdoors into the wee hours
playing cards or
or checkers or whatever
it was a different world
[Music]
infinitely safer now what about family
structure tom again i'm quoting you most
black children were being raised in two
parent families in 1960.
30 years after the liberal welfare state
the great majority of black children
were being raised by single parents yes
how what what what's the what how does
that by the way we should note
that
pat patrick moynihan publishes the
moynihan report in 1965
and he's alarmed because the
illegitimacy rate among black
families is 25 then
now among whites it's over a third
hispanics it's over half and among
african americans it's over 70 percent
what's going on there
well this is how again this too you find
the same thing in britain you find it in
uh
france in norway you find it in the
western world
uh in fact uh there's a dissolution of
the family structure oh yeah there are
any number of western nations where
forty percent of the children are
raised with with only one parent right
uh at the extremes
uh ice
compared to
asian countries
at the extremes of iceland it's two out
of three
uh children born are raised in a single
parent
uh in south korea it's one out of 66.
wow
wow
and so what
that's the welfare state what yes it is
are you you're paying you you're
creating a situation where if the uh
first of all
well you're creating a situation where
if the man stays there the the
government will not give them give the
woman welfare
uh and if he leaves he uh it will
you're nodding big facts
this i completely agree with because um
and it's something you've touched on a
few times
when you asked a question about um
abortion financial
abortion providing welfare
um
gives negative incentives to do the
wrong thing because there's something to
fall back on and when they're suffering
to fall back on you don't do what's
necessary to prevent the problem in the
first place
see because to me i think that's
one of the biggest reasons in the wealth
gap in the u.s is the welfare state
i think that it disproportionately
affected the black community
which i don't disagree with for example
in california one of the when they
implemented a minimum wage loss one of
the first the number one group affected
was black teenagers
some argue that law was racist
because they were black teens were
growing in employment like the boast so
then you have a bunch of boys on the
streets with nothing to do but they've
got money
no they don't have money wait so sorry
you said so the minimum wage law was
implemented in california yeah
and the number one people that whose
jobs were cut was black okay
so when they when they had to cut jobs
they were the first ones to go they're
the most affected so they were they were
first the most employed and then they
were the most affected by that law
so then you have a bunch of teenagers on
the street with nothing to do
i think we can both attest that if you
have nothing going on
you're going to make up something to do
and it's often it's not good yeah yeah
yeah now me i had a lot to do as a
teenager
so
but
if i look at my background and where i
came from it was it was either hustle
or do the negative things that were kind
of implying yeah fortunately for me and
my friend like we used to work illegally
okay like we used to work illegally like
i remember the guy my friend being
um worked for got fired because he
wasn't playing people illegally but we
used to be out here just grinding so we
used to do paper round we used to like
buy cookies and knock on people's doors
to sell cookies just to make money but
often
kids who aren't as business savvy as
that will turn to what is easily
identifiable when you live in those type
of environments which is drugs and stuff
like that right so i can see how that
makes a lot of sense and again goes back
to what you were saying earlier about um
you know if you let the market demand
what people work for regardless of what
they want to do it puts more people in
work instead of having to work towards a
threshold that makes it more selective
and it was around it was around that
time too
when birth control was invented
roe versus wade was similar to that time
and as we talked about yesterday 80 of
planned parenthoods are in minority
communities
and
um on top of that they paid the mom to
take the data out of the home
so it's like you're implementing all
these policies that are catastrophic to
a community
and just a nuclear home in general yeah
yeah so look at that i've been
enlightened even more now yeah dangerous
but information information is powerful
no no this guy honestly like if you ever
want to read
i want to read these books now
black rednecks white liberals his best
book yeah it's so good i
yeah it's i'm going to invest yeah you
should i'm going to invest and so
they're paying they're paying when you
pay people not to get married more
people don't get married right right
okay so so another stat is that in the
u.s um
i forgot it was there's three things but
if if a black person got married held a
job
and didn't have kids outside of wedlock
they economically either performed the
same or outperformed whites really
that's crazy yeah
you guys don't roast me in the comments
if if i don't remember if there was they
out i wanted to say outperform but i
they might have been the same i don't
remember all right listen if we all we
already it's what it is
okay what have happened
if lyndon johnson instead of becoming a
liberal
had remained a crusty tough skeptical
texas texas conservative yes which is
certainly the way he started his career
if he if lyndon johnson had embraced the
constrained
vision
instead of instituting the war on
poverty and the great society and so
forth what would the country look like
today a lot better you would not have
the same rates of crime and so on
because you see you can't have a welfare
state in a democratic country unless you
first have a welfare state vision and
when you buy all the assumptions of that
vision then you're buying a lot of
trouble one of the one of the episodes i
think epitomized it was in france in
this case
uh that there were attacks knife attacks
by various people from north africa
against chinese people in uh in some
suburbs of paris
and one of the
things that
the attacker said you know that
why are you attacking the chinese and it
wasn't because anything the chinese had
done to them he said they have nice
clothes and big cars
that's not fair
i mean that's you know
egalitarianism as a philosophy is one
thing but the actual consequences of it
are mean things like resenting other
people's good fortune right
all right so
one response to the gap
again i returned to this gap between
african-americans and other americans
affirmative action yes which brings us
back to your alma mater harvard
accordingly i know i'll never live it
down you'll never live it down yes
you once told me that the principal
benefit of a harvard degree was never
again having to be impressed by anybody
who had harvard degrees
absolutely i swear to god the dumbest
people i've ever met in my life are the
most educated i agree like i have met
some of the dumbest smart people
because
i think the way they they judge
smartness is quite different like
because a lot of people you can
regurgitate information before an exam
but then there's not a lot of people who
actually take time to learn that
information and i feel like being less
intelligent
based on the standards of intelligence
that um educational institutions deploy
means that you have to work a lot harder
to retain information that you have so
like for me for example when i was in
school my reading age was bogus that's
what i didn't like i didn't take to the
learning style that was given to me in
school then i started watching anime
what i loved i loved anime so much yeah
that i couldn't watch the dubs anymore i
had to watch it subbed and that boosted
my reading age
above where it needed to be in school so
like i went from like
literally stuttering in every word to be
like a sick reader just because i used
to watch anime yeah but it just it just
caters to different learning styles
so yeah i i completely agree but i think
there's common sense and there's iq and
some people have a high iq but no common
sense i know a guy oh my gosh he was so
smart he works at a tech company and i
forgot what school he went to but it was
like some ivy league and i was arguing
with him if a man was a man and a woman
was a woman
i'm like how do you graduate ivy league
and you're still telling me you don't
know the difference between a boy and a
girl
like
again
it was like the dumbest argument i've
ever had in my life and it makes you
think like
what makes you so special
that's what you say that's what you say
so
these are figures that were published in
the harvard crimson the student
newspaper in the harvard class of 2019
these are the kids who will be
graduating next june the average s.a.t
score for black students was 21.49
by the way these are all good scores but
for black students 2149 white students
22-18 asian students
2300. well now that must be reasonable
because it's taking place at harvard the
seat
of reason
well well that wasn't quite how i
described it when i was there
affirmative action is that is that
we ought not to be doing this
you know there are various uh
laws and policies that benefit one group
at the expense of another
but i think affirmative action has the
distinction of being one that harms
everybody though in different ways
and so you there
there's a lot of evidence
that there are black kids who have all
the qualifications to be successes in
college who nevertheless are failures
because they are systematically
mismatched with institutions whose
standards they don't meet even though
they may meet the standards of 80 or 90
percent of the colleges in america
i remember first aware of this when i
was teaching at cornell and i found that
half the black students at cornell were
on some kind of academic probation and
so i went over to the administration
building look up the sats of these
students the average black student at
cornell at that time scored at the 75th
percentile
which is pretty darn good yes
and so that means that that most
colleges in this country they would have
no trouble and many of them would be on
the dean's list
but at cornell the average liberal arts
student at that time was in the 99th
percentile
and and when you when you when you're
teaching students like that
you teach at a pace
that most people
of any race cannot keep up with and i i
was it was always complained that i was
assigning all kinds of reading
but heck i'm teaching kids who are in
the top one percent they can they they
can keep up with with the reading that
i'm assigning
uh so cornell was taking very talented
black kids and spending four years
teaching them to feel inadequate yes
and succeeding at that
um
isn't that crazy literally i was just
thinking that that's wild
yeah i mean have you you guys have
quotas here
yes yeah i couldn't quote them to you
but we do have quarters yeah yeah
it's it's weird because what do you
think about it quotas are so racist
because they're basically saying black
people can't get in or do the job on
their own
i agree
my old
my old style of thinking was
what this would do by invoking this if
there is some such a thing as um
what's the word it's
not not ingrained bias but
like an unconscious bias would mean that
over time these institutions would
naturally have to change because of the
fact that you know different ethnic
groups were there
so naturally they would invoke nepotism
and through nepotism you'd have a multi
um
a varied demographic of people
and and that should change the system
but again
um
i think
merit also has a part to play you know
if you're good enough to get into
somewhere
you should work and achieve it and does
it really feel like an achievement if
you know you got there because you are
black
i don't know if it feels the same and
then it causes discrimination because
people will assume that the people that
are there are just there because they're
black yes because that's what's
happening in a lot of schools
and it hurts the black kids because they
fail out
at higher rates and it's funny because
the administrators will pat themselves
on the back and saying they're like
helping black kids get into these
they're just me they don't care they
just meet your numbers yeah but it's bad
because
it's like
you're basically saying that black kids
can't get in on their own
and aren't smart enough to so this is
the way it's difficult because i don't
think it's necessarily i don't think
it's a one-size-fits-all
problem because there is this problem
like you know people identify more of
what they see i mean
what looks more like them so you're more
naturally inclined to
bring a white person into school than a
black person if you was having an
interview really because everyone i
hired has been black
[Music]
yeah
more often than not if you people
identify people who are more like them
so if we're just looking at names on a
piece of paper
which again might be slightly different
for us because the surnames and such
that there probably would be like white
producers names
[Music]
but in the uk for example i did i did
this test myself so i applied to the
same job with two different names that
is a very small test but it still came
up with the kind of evidence that was
that was necessary for it okay um i
can't remember what the name but one
name was very stereotypically white and
one name was my real name okay exact
same tv no differences okay um the one
that got the interview was the
stereotypically white name yeah well i
mean that happens i'm sure but i just
don't think that a quota will solve it
i'm i'm undecided
because i do think nepotism is a very
important thing so like in the industry
i work here now
it's not an industry widely known to
black people it's more my dad did this
and i told my son my son's brought in
his friends et cetera and through that
it kind of spreads
um so if you're able to invoke nepotism
at high positions then naturally if
those people grow into higher positions
in those companies then they naturally
become diverse over time to the point
where you won't need quotas
the only thing is where it's still quite
new
um we're gonna go through this
kind of tricky phase of having to accept
it for what it is but hopefully over
time if this only is something that is
temporary it should naturally change as
people start to see more diverse
environments you know how long they've
been saying that go on they've been
saying that's a temporary thing since
like the 50s
how long have these quotas been in place
though since the 60s since the 60s yeah
that's what a lot of these policies were
implemented and again and in a lot of
situations like
again just because there's a disparity
it doesn't mean discrimination black
people make up more of the nba or white
people discriminated against
see and you know what i remember having
this debate and and that was something
that was brought up and like women women
are engineers are women discriminated
against
different groups value different things
yes asian there's more asians in in ivy
league schools does that mean white
people are discriminated against
different cultures want to do different
things and so if you're going around
saying it needs to be representative of
the population in industries that you
know nothing about it doesn't really
make sense it doesn't make sense and
worse yet people don't stay in those
industries to invoke the nepotism i'm
talking about because they'll just leave
at some point because it's not their
true passion right and it just depends
on the culture because different like
i'm sure
i don't know what nigerians do for a
living typically
but i'm sure you can think of a couple
industries that come to your head right
now as we're talking that a lot of
people that are an idea what full and
massive fruit
i
yeah and like like i'm german we're
engineers all my brothers are engineers
and so it just depends on the person but
what you're asking is you're asking
third parties to make a decision and
putting basically putting a gun to
business owner's head saying i know best
for your business about who you should
hire i know better than you
and honestly i think as a business owner
you have the right to hire who you want
true true
but if you're but if you're being racist
you're going to be at a competitive
disadvantage because you're not hiring
the people with the best skills true but
then they do say that um the more
diverse the board the better performing
the business so if you have a mixture of
different ethnic backgrounds and genders
within a business then they outperform
businesses that are
um consistent right that's that's fine
then you should give the business owners
the right to choose that and i agree
with that so like why does the
government get to say who i have to hire
um
i'm definitely becoming more consistent
because i i started this is my business
right yeah so
what if they came in and said you need
to hire white people
you just be like leave me alone let me
do what i need to do for my business
right but or if it was reversed let's
just say they were white right and if
they said okay you need to hire black
people and i'm like no i picked the best
people for the job and that's just what
they look like but are they picking the
best people for the job i think that is
always going to be the tricky question
if they're not picking the best people
for the job they'll go out of business
yeah because we're in it like business
society yeah it's hard to run most
businesses fail in general yeah yeah
majority yeah the majority of people
that start businesses don't succeed
so if if you're dumb enough to to hire
people
just based off what they look like
you're not gonna win
yeah because this is my dad says he says
the hardest part about business is
finding talent and keeping them true
because if you if you find someone
that's talented like they they can
everybody wants them yeah and they have
the options yeah and so if you if you're
like honestly just just my opinion like
if you're a super like highly skilled
person it's so easy to stand out because
honestly it's hard to find them yeah it
took me forever to find a good team i
didn't do this myself for so long not
big facts
in in most cases you let the market
decide um and the market
is harsh yeah so
i agree so no quotas
do you know what i'm being persuaded
okay i'm being persuaded okay
wait let's see okay
well i think we can do part two a
different day okay this is a pretty long
video i know you said you have to get
going yeah yeah yeah but i'm enjoying
i'm not gonna lie it's a good video it
is it is just opening my eyes because
information is king like you and not
enough none of us not enough of us have
access to
real credible sources that are out here
doing the raw research so when you do
find someone that is and again he's a
black man
so
arguably he doesn't have an agenda
against black people he wants a success
for well more generally humans that's
why he's made in one particular book two
sides of the argument
and he hasn't taken aside he's just
giving you the information and saying
look this these are the two sides of the
argument and you take your pick
and i think
these things are very important for
people to know because again these
aren't the things that people are taught
in schools
we're taught divisive information that
makes you know one people look superior
one people look belittled
um and they don't show ways out or
or try to show the true reality of the
situation so that you have the right
state of mind to better your situation
so
pick this up the internet's a great
equalizer it is
but again finding these people
you have to be switched on and you have
to be you have to be connected so i
always always say that you know surround
yourself with people that help to
elevate you because you you do have a
lot of friendship groups that you know
they don't sit down and watch this stuff
so you're more valuable than some of my
friends already
actually i get a lot of friends to watch
this video
because you're actively helping people
to better their mentality because people
deploy this victim mentality and say
everything is
their fault you know there's no personal
responsibility no and that's what i
realized the most valuable thing i have
had in my life is like a dad that gave
me good advice
because the more i'm on youtube the more
i see like a lot of people didn't grow
up with that like two-parent
50 of people right because half of
marriages end in divorce and that's if
they got married
so a lot of people didn't grow up with
that and i didn't realize like how much
of an advantage i'm at just from having
that like conservative background
structure and like
families that are like entrepreneurs and
can help me with like the stuff so this
is rich that poured that scenario i've
not read that book it's a good book but
it's it's
it emulates what you're what you're
saying well we can do part two next i
would love to i would love to um tell
the people where they can find you
again you can find me at who's
underscore eddie underscore or you can
find me um at the domino effect podcast
um i'm gonna have pearl on at one point
but listen i'm looking forward to part
two he's bringing me a feminist right i
listen i'm bringing her a girl that's
four women i think you might actually
know her i think she follows you
interestingly enough oh yeah but we'll
talk about off-camera okay but um it's
gonna be very good i can't wait i'm very
excited okay
okay guys um you already know the deal
you better subscribe to the channel ring
that notification bell subscribe i'm
going to squish your head in my pen
like the video on your way out and i
will talk to you next time